thanks for coming
this talk is about extreme multi-label
classification
with an application in the biomedical
nlp domain
my name is nick soros i'm the founder of
mantis
before mantis studied
at imperial college advanced computing
i've worked as data scientists for a
couple of years
in some london startups
prior to mantis i was leading the data
science team at the welcome trust uh
which this project was based on
you can also find me
with the username and source in a couple
of platforms twitter github linkedin
and if you're interested you can also
send me an email
so this is a little bit cut i hope this
is not going to cause problems
but before we talk about extreme
multi-label classification it might be
worth doing a quick reminder on
multi-label classification
so this is very similar type of problem
as multi-class classification
with the difference that each example
can have more than one classes
a typical
example of a multi-label problem is
setting categories in movies
as we see here
the extreme multi-label classification
problem
differs on the amount of labels
used which are typically in the
thousands or millions
as an example
of a problem when amazon is trying to
assign
tags into their products
or when bing is trying to find relevant
search queries when you search
or categorizing wikipedia articles is a
type of extreme multi-label
classification problem
in
in practice amazon and microsoft are
quite active in this area in extreme
multi-level classification because they
they're interested in these type of
problems and wikipedia is also a common
testbed
for for these types of problems
another interesting characteristic which
you can see is that there is a large
vocabulary
in this uh these problems of thousands
of tokens
and
which is quite large and adds an
additional challenge
so in the biomedical domain
in particular there is um a common
problem is um that is an extreme
multi-label classification one is
assigning um
tags into biomedical publications um
so
this is applying mesh tags which are
tags like blood pressure hypertension
essentially categorizing into a very
coarse um there are there are 29 000
it's a very fine grained system
for categorizing biomedical publication
called mess
and actually there is it's the job of
expert annotators to annotate biomedical
publications
when they're indexed to be part of
pubmed which is a database of biomedical
publications so there is the motivation
to automate that process and as a result
there's also a competition called bioass
that centralizes all these
data sets
which conveniently exist it consists of
14 million biomedical publications that
are already tagged with those mesh tags
and this is the problem i was working on
and
and
the vocabulary in this setting is around
400 000 tokens so it's a quite a large
vocabulary
so welcome trust which is where this
project took place is a large biomedical
funder
one of the largest in the world and the
motivation behind the project was
prior to uh
creating this uh this algorithm
welcome had
had the had had a way of categorizing
their grants which was very coarse it
was either
the funding team that was giving
the research grants
to researchers something like infectious
diseases research team or mental health
what you see on the left so
you know the callers are just these few
categories of the different
teams that were assigned they're giving
grants and then or
the type of
money they were giving such as a
scholarship or a an individual grant to
an um to a researcher
but they didn't have a fine
a fine grain system
so for example they couldn't easily say
standard in a standard way how many how
much money they were giving to malaria
or hiv or any type of
biomedically related disease or theme
so when working with
in this setting
in extreme multi-label classification
and
there are four main challenges uh that
we have to overcome in order to uh to
work around this uh scale
this is the amount of space models tend
to take in
in disk
the memory you need to
to load the data and the models as
you're training
the time it takes to train
of course um and also inference time
sometimes depending on how you're
applying
the model so let's talk a little bit
about those problems starting with the
amount of disk space required and
so if we want to train a very simple
model and
like a baseline of a traditional tfidfs
vm in the kind of setting i said before
and so mess tagging
and we train one individual classifier
for each label which is typical in those
cases then we would have to have one
parameter per vocabulary term we have a
large vocabulary term of four hundred
thousand
and typically scikit-learn if we use
ikey learn uses 64 bits so eight bits so
this would require in total around 92
gigabytes just to stir one single
baseline model
which is quite large and inconvenient to
work with
but fortunately there is an easy way to
solve to solve this problem
which is
not all of these vocabulary terms need
to have parameters that
contribute to the classification
actually in order of magnitude the less
parameters are needed most of the times
you can control that this is just an
order of magnitude calculation
but most of them
most of the weights for these terms are
near zero you can actually set a
threshold pretty easily you can say i'm
going to zero out all the parameters
that are below say 0.1
and check whether that affects
performance and
and
and then
actually conveniently scikit-learn in
particular also for some classifiers it
provides a specify
function that creates that transforms
the parameters into a sparse matrix
essentially requiring only the non-zero
elements to be stored which reduces the
size
like an order of magnet less to around
one gigabyte so
that's one way
that you can work with having a reduced
size
for your models
interestingly neural networks in these
settings are more compact than than a
baseline of a traditional algorithm
so for example if we do a very simple
architecture which is now
a little bit cut but with an embedding
for the 400 000 terms say 300
dimensionality for the embedding and
then convolution filters if we maintain
the sequence length on 300
most of the parameters as you see and
then we do a mean pull and then we do
like a linear layer uh on the dimension
of the vector that we represent say the
grant or the sentence
to the outputs we want to classify most
most of the parameters are being
consumed by the
embedding table as you see and the
parameter
space is
low enough for the size of the network
to be
not too big
so this is interesting and unintuitive
it was when i started working at least
on this problem
i also want to mention another trick you
can use
for using a size independent of
specifying the parameters for example
which is you can you don't have to use a
complete vocabulary splitting by some
sort of white space
you can
rely on sub word organization so the
same
way
bert and transformers models use and
which allows you to instead of represent
its token represent subtokens and
subwords
and represent a similarly large
vocabulary with a smaller set of terms
for example in burst case it was using a
vocabulary of 30 000 we can use
something similar
and reduce
and induce the size
quite significantly even before
considering
using sparse parameters for example
so this is the disk space memory
if we actually try to load this data
into memory and
for example to do scikit-learn tends to
think that things fit into memory
sometimes
the target vector alone would be 14
million rows because it's 40 million
examples and then 29 000 columns because
it's 29 000 labels
so it would actually be we don't see it
here but it will be
in the terabytes
and fortunately again most of these
columns are actually non are zero
they're most of the elements this this
matrix is quite sparse most of the
elements are zero a few elements are
non-zero
and if we represent this matrix as a
sparse matrix we can actually load it
pretty easily into memory again like it
falls an order of magnitude less nonzero
elements per example
instead of 29 000 around 29 tags apply
per example
and actually conveniently again you
cannot see
but scikit-learn provides a parameter
when you're when you're trying to
represent
when you're trying to convert this data
into um into a matrix
which is
sparse output equals true and then you
can just get your space matrix you can
actually fit in some cases those data
into memory
but of course this is 29 000 tags and as
i said in the beginning some problems
have millions of tags so if you actually
scale that two million then you run into
the same problem
so the typical way
i wonder if we can fix that splitting of
the screen at some point
but the typical way we solve the
this problem
of the data not fitting into memories by
not loading the data into memory in the
first place so
so for example as i'm showing here you
can just iterate over your data one by
one
and then and then use that data into
batches to train or one by one you can
train two batches of one
which is typical on what we do when
we're doing deep learning a little bit
less typical for psychic learn for
example
inside kit learn though even though it's
not
the
the most common way we do you can
actually use a streaming way of doing
this and some algorithms
like tfidf vectorizer for example
support
giving it a generator
so instead of a list
because inside them even though they
don't advertise it as far as i'm aware
they consume it in a for loop in a four
um in
using a for loop which means they can
consume the iterator
instead of for example you know needing
like a seven or 30 gigabytes if it can
fit into memory
um doing it with a generator it would be
quite light memory wise
in terms of um
classifiers the typical way we do that
in scikit-learn for example is with
partial fit
and as you can see here like it looks
very similar to what we do in deep
learning so you have to do the training
loop yourself you have to iterate over
your data multiple times
you have to draw on examples and then
you just feed them into a into a partial
fit and this is again
draws reduces the memory requirement
quite significantly
and you can stop wherever you want even
when your epochs end or you can have a
stopping criterion exit
cool so this is memory
training time-wise um
the situation is a little bit more
straightforward because fortunately as
you know we have all these different
instances in aws
or any cloud provider you use
this is aws in particular so
usually the most you have to do is just
scale with you know one line change or
one parameter change
in scikit-learn for example there is an
jobs parameter then you can use as many
cpus as you have available and you can
use bigger instances to get more cpus in
deep learning frameworks like python's
tester flow it tends to use most cpus by
default
if you want to use a gpu and you want to
scale across gpus which we had to do for
this project again it's most of the
times it's a one-line change in those
frameworks so it's it's a relatively
easy
um
way to to reduce training time
but there is also one more thing you can
do in these settings
and this is called negative sampling and
this relies on the fact that a lot of
a lot of your examples again contain
you have a lot more negative examples
and positives and
in these 14 million examples you may
you can think that in one column could
have a few positives
for that label or you know maybe a
thousand but not a million
so there are a couple of ways you can do
negative sampling and it's not only a
trick being used in extreme multi-label
classification but one way is if you
group somehow or cluster
you can do some pre-clustering of your
labels so that they're sort of similar
one technique which is going to be used
in a model i'm going to show afterwards
if you cluster them so they're grouped
in similarly looking clusters then you
can
uh remove all the rows of those clusters
that contain only zeros you're going to
keep only the rows that contain at least
one label is activated on that cluster
and this reduces this throws away a lot
of the data and then you can use that
reduced data set per cluster to train
either individually one by one
classifiers or different
neural networks
but with much less data than the
original data and this alone will
will converge most much faster
okay and then we have inference time so
inverse inference time is not always
relevant and important so for example in
our case
with the welcome trust and
we can
predict all the grants that
welcome was giving overnight using using
a batch job so
so that's fine this was taking some
hours still so reducing inference time
is important in some sense but it's not
we didn't have a requirement to have the
algorithm in real time
sometimes though you have to have like a
faster response
so one trick you can do there
is called the binary tree and it's
commonly used in this setting so
instead of
learning one classifier to do all the
labels you can again as we're saying
before you can cluster you can do a
recursive clustering you can cluster
into two or into as many clusters as you
want and then cluster again your labels
creating a a binary tree
and then at inference time if you do
that then you can go as you go down the
tree you don't have to now do
predictions for all the labels as you
would naively have to do because you
have to decide which labels apply
you can actually slowly go and
traverse the tree and only do a
prediction for say you know a few labels
or hundreds because you're not going to
visit the entire tree not everything
will be activated you will either go
right or left based on which supplies
and then a subset of the tree you will
have to actually calculate the
probabilities and then say these these
labels apply but you skip calculating
for a lot more other
labels
yeah similar even though i think in this
case it's um you have to use
like a custom weight of doing it you
cannot use some sort of divide and
conquer out of the box i would say
in its layer i mean i guess i didn't
mention like a different classifier
applies as well so you have to have you
know more models maybe than before
because each layer layer you either have
to have one per node or one that like
it's a different multi-label
classification problem
this is also a technique being used in
multi-class classification as well
sometimes because you have to do a soft
marks over the classes and then that's
quite expensive if you have a lot of
classes in imagine it for example so
they actually do this sometimes to speed
up the soft max calculation
cool let's let's look at some models
so i want to highlight just three of the
models we tried
and then
some techniques using those models and
some additional techniques
so the one of the first things we did
was create a custom architecture based
on literature which was based on uh
the space like a framework similar to
what space is doing of a bed and code
that tends to predict the encoding layer
was inspired by birth in the sense that
there is a future extractor and layer
normalization after which with the
residual connection that we repeat four
times
and then of course instead of multi-head
attention we just do one deconvolution
we actually developed that at the time
that bert was sort of
just new so it was kind of um
this was at a time like a good
architecture that we started playing
with then we added hierarchical
attention which basically adds one one
attention vector per
i mean it's up to you for us we actually
again inspired from birth try to keep
the sequence length so input and output
of those layers are the same
say for example 400 tokens and 400 in
the exit same with the hierarchical
attention and then we add the fully
connected layer in the end to predict
the labels
and this went quite well for a subpart
of mess
so the disease subpart is only 4 000
labels and this
did around 63 percent the state of the
art is around 70.
and
but we had some difficulty scaling up to
the entire
the entirety of the 29 000 labels
so this which you kind of see is
a really interesting work that is now
also in production at the welcome which
is a very fast like this is a technique
this is a model from amazon
that is using most of the tricks that i
mentioned before um
so the way it works is uh it's a general
framework for how to work in extreme
multi-label classification problems
the first thing they do to reduce the
the the size of the problem is in to go
from let's say millions of thousands of
labels to do a clustering to a lower
number of labels that they control
so the cluster first the labels
and then they do a multi-label
classification model to predict the
reduced set of labels to produce which
clusters apply
and that is quite fast because it's a
reduced sample
and in those clusters they do negative
sampling as we said before so this goes
quite fast and in
um and then after they only pick the
clusters that
have been predicted and on those they do
a final ranking model so let's say let's
say four clusters applied
that contain its 40 labels only for
those they actually rank them with a
linear model to pre to get the final
predictions similarly to what we were
saying before with the binary tree they
don't look at all the labels which is
quite fast in french as well
they actually do that recursively
building a binary tree as well but the
important details is kind of like this
three-step process they actually do this
is a linear model uh which did
which achieved 56 percent a little bit
less than the neural one which is kind
of what you get with linear models in
that problem that i was working on
but they also have a transformers-based
model called x-transformers which in
theory
goes plugs into the
second stage instead of doing a linear
model there you can do a transformer to
produce the clusters and then that
in theory works better than linear in
our case we didn't see that performance
boost
but where we did see the performance
boost was in this last
technique this last model we built which
is
uses another technique which is very
common in these settings which is called
multi-label attention so the way this
works in this case is we have a birth
model
as we would have and then we get the
outputs and instead of having like let's
say linear layer that sort of goes from
the outputs maybe with an average or
maybe from one of the tokens into the
labels
there is one attention
vector per label so separate that's why
it's called multi-label attention the
thing you see on the right
on the left but on the right of the left
graph
one per label which sort of learns the
intricacies of the label to sort of only
attend to the tokens that are relevant
for that label and then there is a just
one hidden layer before you go into a
one output urine to say whether that
label applies
this is
widely used in the extreme multi-label
classification literature for the best
performing models and so we added that
on top of birds which has already been
done before in a paper called birth mesh
so we just took the idea from there
and this again
scaled to all the labels
performing around the same as the actual
neural network we saw before but for all
their labels around 63
and
we also made that model uh available in
the hiking phase hub so you can download
it and do predictions it's quite
expensive to train those models so it
took us um four days with eight gpus and
um
so it's quite it takes a little bit of
time and a little bit of cost so you can
just skip that and just download the
model and use
um
cool there are two more things actually
you can do in this setting which is
quite common with sort of boost
performance say around two percentage uh
which in our case we we haven't rolled
out but that are worth um mentioning
one is called threshold optimization so
unlike multi-class classification where
you have a softmax and you get
probabilities
here you usually have a sigmoid in the
end and you get the probability per
output
and then you have a threshold say for
example above 0.5
all these labels are applicable
usually you have to play a little bit
with the threshold because not all
examples have the same number of
examples so some get you know like the
the the
scores you get are not saying normalized
so you can for example do a little bit
better if you use a lower threshold
mostly but you can actually do even
better if you use
an optimal threshold per label so you go
one by one it's labeled and say you try
some values for the threshold
and then you check whether that improves
the score and then you do that
iteratively because changing one
threshold might sort of affect the other
labels so you go one by one and then you
sort of iteratively do that until
there's no change and then you end up
with one threshold value per label
which is the optimal threshold value for
the
for your problem
which again inspired from a paper that
um
and the algorithm from the paper is here
and there's also one more thing which is
uh unsurprisingly doing some sort of
assembling in the end to get a little
bit of more boost and the problem again
as i said is it's quite expensive to
train say for example four models or
five or three and then sort of do some
sort of ensemble with them but there's
one way you can actually train one model
which is quite interesting and a lot of
people use in this setting and get a
couple of models and this is called
snapshot ensemble
and the way this works is you decide in
you split your training steps say in 10
different or five
groups
and then and then you basically reset
the learning rate you set your learning
rate really high
every time you reach that um say 50
steps or
wherever you split your
your training time
and then this sort of resets the loss
you so it's like resetting the learning
process in a nearby space so the model
sort of converges slightly differently
as you can see from the graph from the
paper that has introduced this
it tends to converge similarly but with
producing a little bit different models
that if you ensemble them together you
get a better performance than the one
model that you would have trained
that's why it's called train one get m
for free and you can just pick the best
performing models from that and combine
them together and you have an ensemble
cool a very quick wrap-up so
we saw most of the techniques in the
literature that have been used in a
couple of papers even though i didn't
mention the actual papers but these are
the main things that
most of them are doing to actually work
in this setting
these are using sparse parameters
to reduce
the size of the models when they get
quite large
using sparse data to be able to work
with the data
uh stream the data of course if uh
if the data is not is big is big
bigger than they would fit into memory
to begin with
or even regardless and then using
multi-cpu gpu setups which we can do
quite easily for reducing the training
time binary tree for reducing the
inference time
then we saw multi-label attention which
is a key component of the state of the
art in this setting
and two tricks threshold optimization
and snap shot and sample
so
what i learned from doing this project
just three things real quick is one the
first model i presented was like a
custom model we created and initially it
made sense because it was inspired from
literature it was
it should be easy to develop and perform
but it actually ended up quite hard so i
guess one thing i'm taking up from this
project is that when when we're going
for a custom model which nowadays maybe
we don't have to do that often because
we use transformers and pre-trained
architectures but it takes time to
stabilize and you know make like
especially if you're in edge cases to
get like a stable
model performing in in your problem
popular libraries can fail units cases
which
refers to the fact that for example if
you do multi-label classification in
scikit-learn
then and you're trying to do the tfid of
svm baseline i i um mentioned then then
that doesn't work out of the box for
example you have to do something custom
because
in that setting of
multi-label and sparse outputs and with
all these things
there's an open issue that um it doesn't
work out of the box you just have to do
something else some so sometimes if
you're working on edge cases again
you know this some frameworks may not
work out of the box
or for example even with pytorch or
tensorflow for me at least i didn't find
an easy way to work with sparse outputs
so the way i went around that is i was
converting the the sparse y vector into
dense every time i was doing the
calculation
and then also the a lot of the
techniques that i mentioned and i mean i
believe they work but uh for me they
didn't work out of the box for example
you know threshold optimization snapped
and assembled they didn't just work if
you try them they look straightforward
and a lot of papers mentioned that they
work for them so i'm sure they work but
i'm just saying that for me at least
they didn't work out of the box it's not
like you read something and then
you know one week after it works
cool so all the code actually is open
source in the first link it's called
grunts tiger welcome trust
and i'll share the slides after as well
and we've blogged extensively about some
of the things i mentioned here in this
talk
but yeah if you have questions you can
send me an email after or now
thank you
hi i'm just coming with the microphone
just if you have a question please raise
your hand
thank you that was a great talk uh quick
question just on evaluation metrics in
these uh
what have you found is it just you know
the traditional accuracy of one or have
you found sort of specific
evaluation metrics uh are better suited
for how these
uh
let's say data sets are labeled uh yes
the so what we used were traditionally
micro precision uh recall and f1 and
which is also used in the research
but there are actually some specific
metrics which i didn't calculate but
they are also reported in this like
there are some hierarchical measures so
in the ms case this is a hierarchical
tree anyway it starts from a group of
seven tags and then it goes down so
there are some metrics which have been
shown to correlate but be also slightly
different that take into account the
tree
there are also some metrics from
retrieval kind of how good are you in
ranking these tags which some people
report
but in all of those metrics different
models come on top so i mean for us we
cared a lot about
f1 but we didn't go any we didn't
calculate any other metrics
so i had a question about the input text
how long is it in these applications is
it so long that you can fit the old text
even in the
neural network models
so it is around
typically or i mean so the biomedical
publications have a title an abstract
and then they have the full text and
typically the data sets use the title
and the abstract which usually falls
around 400 like you use a 400 sequence
length and you're fine
but there is some work that actually
extends that to the entire text
and nowadays you can do that also with
transformers quite easily you can just
use a longer transformer like a long
former for example
or even in the case of course of
a baseline techniques then that's fine
you don't care you can increase a little
bit of vocabulary just to account for
more text but they work as well
but for neural networks you can just
switch to something that works with
longer
oh
text
thank you um uh first of all
really good uh presentation
i learned quite a bit um a quick
question um any challenges when you were
trying to get this you know get the data
labeled i mean there would be a lot of
data to label so i just wondered
you know how was the data labeled and
and also too
how much of the data was labeled
so as i mentioned in the beginning we
were fortunate that actually this has
been done
for us from these expert annotators that
they do this as a living
for indexing them in
pubmed
so we use biomedical publications and
they're already come with those tags but
actually now that you mentioned labeling
we i mean of course we train on
biomedical publications and we apply on
welcome grants which is like a slightly
transfer here
but so we did label like a subset of
welcome grants say around 2000 with some
mesh tags that apply not all of them of
course applied for each one and we
evaluated how well the performance
transfer and it was actually doing even
better in welcome maybe because
we use less
you know less of the tags are applicable
and for those it works quite well to
differentiate which one is which
thank you um
her question so basically you trained on
um
biomedical publications but you applied
it to med to the ground have you
investigated adversarial examples where
the text is let's say engineered to
maximize the number of tags uh one gets
um
since grants are reviewed only by you
know like welcome trust let's say
whereas
um you're trained on a very nice data
that is not
uh that doesn't have those adversarial
examples in it because it's reviewed by
you know a publication like the
conference
committees that uh
would see past that so you don't have
adversarial examples in those data sets
this is a it's a great shout um
so i'm no longer working on this project
but my colleagues at welcome they're
here so you know they can take your
suggestion and apply it but um
with that we've done a little bit of
work on the ethical implications of this
because we care about whether for
example you know the wrong tags are
applied
and we've did noticed some problems that
we tried to mitigate but what you're
also saying i mean of course we haven't
advertised very publicly to researchers
so that they can try to do you know
optimization on their application but
it's a it's a good sound we should we
should check that
any more questions
cool okay thanks so much
[Applause]